This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Shortly after the 9-11 attacks, a photo made its way around the internet. It showed a man standing on the observation deck at the World Trade Center in New York City. His face is expressionless, unsmiling. He's wearing a knitted black cap, sunglasses, and an unzipped parka. Behind him a deep blue sky, views of Manhattan and the Hudson River. But there's something else behind him too. A plane. It's headed straight toward the tower. Rumor had it, the man died that day and his camera was later pulled from the rubble. It's an amazing shot and an amazing story and it's totally false.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。9-11袭击事件发生后不久，一张照片在互联网上流传开来。照片显示一名男子站在纽约世界贸易中心的观景台上。他面无表情，没有笑容。他戴着黑色针织帽、太阳镜，穿着一件拉链没拉上的派克大衣。在他身后是深蓝色的天空，以及曼哈顿和哈德逊河的景色。但他身后还有别的东西。一架飞机。它正径直朝大楼飞去。传言说，那名男子当天就死了，他的相机后来从废墟中被找了出来。这是一张令人惊叹的照片，一个令人惊叹的故事，但它完全是假的。
The man is Peter Goosley and he's Hungarian. The picture was snapped several years before the terrorist attacks. After 9-11 Peter Goosley photoshopped in the plane and emailed the image to a few friends as a joke. Those friends shared the image with their friends and their friends shared it with more friends and soon the photo was everywhere. 10 years after the attacks, Peter Goosley publicly apologized. He said he was ashamed and sorry and hadn't considered the consequences. He said, I never thought it would go out of my tight circle of friends. That should have been the end of it, but it wasn't.
这名男子叫彼得·古斯利，他是匈牙利人。这张照片是在恐怖袭击发生前几年拍摄的。9-11事件后，彼得·古斯利用Photoshop把飞机加了进去，并作为玩笑通过电子邮件发给了几个朋友。那些朋友把照片分享给了他们的朋友，他们的朋友又分享给了更多朋友，很快这张照片就传遍了各地。袭击发生10年后，彼得·古斯利公开道歉。他说他感到羞愧和抱歉，当时没有考虑到后果。他说，我从没想过它会传出我那个小小的朋友圈。那本该是这件事的终点，但事实并非如此。
The image turned Peter Goosley into a meme star. On social media today, he's known as the tourist guy, or sometimes as the tourist of death. Strangers online have photoshopped the same image of an expressionless Peter Goosley, with his parkour, knitcap and sunglasses into all kinds of famous scenes where something terrible has just happened or is about to happen. He's in the motorcade with John F. Kennedy moments before the president gets shot in a cave next to Osama bin Laden in the foreground as the Hindenburg explodes. Whether he wants this role today is not up to Peter Gosley anymore.
这张照片让彼得·古斯利成了网红明星。在今天的社交媒体上，他被称为“游客哥”，有时也被称为“死亡游客”。网上的陌生人把彼得·古斯利面无表情、穿着派克大衣、戴着针织帽和太阳镜的同一张照片，PS进了各种可怕事件刚刚发生或即将发生的著名场景中。他出现在约翰·肯尼迪遇刺前几分钟的车队里，出现在奥萨马·本·拉登旁边的洞穴里，出现在兴登堡号飞艇爆炸的前景中。他今天是否想要这个角色，已经由不得彼得·古斯利了。
The tourist of death now belongs to the internet. It does what it wants with the image. Coming up, we have the story of a young man who made a terrible mistake on social media, a mistake that destroyed the future he had imagined for himself. This story is about a fault line that runs through our lives. On social media, we're encouraged to be quick, clever, edgy. The funny videos and amusing banter we engage in seem low stakes.
“死亡游客”现在属于互联网了。它随心所欲地处理这张照片。接下来，我们将讲述一个年轻人的故事，他在社交媒体上犯了一个可怕的错误，这个错误摧毁了他为自己设想的未来。这个故事关于我们生活中贯穿的一条断层线。在社交媒体上，我们被鼓励要反应迅速、聪明、前卫。我们参与的那些搞笑视频和有趣的调侃似乎风险很低。
But they are not. A larger world is watching. It's usually silent, but every now and then, something we can undo the damage. Beauty sometimes appears in unexpected places. I'm sitting in a low chair woven from bungee cord, staring at the crumpled sheets of an unmade bed. To my right is a desk cluttered with textbooks, a stick of deodorant, and a half-eaten jar
但事实并非如此。一个更大的世界正在注视着。它通常是沉默的，但偶尔，我们能弥补造成的伤害。美有时会出现在意想不到的地方。我坐在用蹦极绳编织的低矮椅子上，盯着一张未整理的床上皱巴巴的床单。我的右边是一张堆满教科书、一根除臭剂和半罐吃剩的
of Nutella. The room has the slight tangy smell of a gymlocker. It belongs to a 20-year-old named William. We're not using his last name for reasons that will become clear shortly. William is a musician. After chatting for a few minutes, he pulls a worn case from under his bed. So this is actually a 1910 violin by a guy named
能多益巧克力酱的桌子。房间里有一股淡淡的储物柜酸味。它属于一个叫威廉的20岁年轻人。出于稍后会明了的原因，我们不使用他的姓氏。威廉是一名音乐家。聊了几分钟后，他从床下拿出一个磨损的琴盒。所以这实际上是一把1910年的小提琴，出自一个叫
Heberlain, yeah, Heinrich Siodor Heberlain, 1910 made in Germany. The Amberwood Gleams. William got this violin when he was just a sophomore in high school. Totally couldn't afford it. I emptied my bank account for it. My parents emptied their bank accounts for it. And my grandparents helped me out too.
赫伯莱因的人之手，是的，海因里希·西奥多·赫伯莱因，1910年德国制造。琥珀色的木头闪闪发光。威廉在高二时得到了这把小提琴。完全买不起。我掏空了我的银行账户才买下它。我父母也掏空了他们的银行账户。我祖父母也帮了我一把。
They did it because William is good. By 9th grade, William's violin instructor was letting him choose what he wanted to play. The first piece I picked to play was Viotis' 22nd violin concerto. I just heard this melody. Wait, no, let me start. Let me start again. That's a different ornament. Wait, no, let me start. Let me start again. That's a different ornament.
他们这样做是因为威廉很有天赋。到九年级时，威廉的小提琴老师已经让他自己选择想演奏的曲目了。我选的第一首曲子是维奥蒂的第22小提琴协奏曲。我只是听到了这段旋律。等等，不，让我开始。让我重新开始。那是不同的装饰音。等等，不，让我开始。让我重新开始。那是不同的装饰音。
It felt strange to hear such elegant music in this messy room. As he plays, William changes. He goes from a boyish 20-year-old to someone mature and intense. His eyes close, his brow furrows, his body swears back and forth as it follows the bow. It's like he's become opening section to that concerto and that would just get stuck in my head so easily that I just I so wanted to play it. You don't need music to play it? Oh no, no, I memorize everything.
在这个凌乱的房间里听到如此优雅的音乐感觉很奇怪。当他演奏时，威廉变了。他从一个孩子气的20岁年轻人变成了一个成熟而专注的人。他闭上眼睛，眉头紧锁，身体随着琴弓的节奏前后摇摆。就像他已经成为了那首协奏曲的开篇部分，那段旋律很容易就卡在我的脑海里，以至于我非常想演奏它。你不需要乐谱就能演奏吗？哦不，不，我背下了所有东西。
For the next half hour, he treats me to a mini concert, one that includes the middle movement of a suite by Ernest Block and compositions by Paganini, Vyutom and Sibelius. After he stashes his violin, the conversation turns to other topics, winding its way eventually to the mathematical symbol, Pai. Just mentioning the word, trip something in Williams' brain. Wait, let's see how many digits of pie I remember. I like to learn them in like sixth grade. Okay. 3.141592653589793238462643332795028419716939993. That's as much as I know.
在接下来的半小时里，他为我举办了一场迷你音乐会，其中包括欧内斯特·布洛赫组曲的中间乐章，以及帕格尼尼、维奥当和西贝柳斯的作品。在他收好小提琴后，谈话转向了其他话题，最终绕到了数学符号“圆周率”上。仅仅提到这个词，就触发了威廉大脑中的某些东西。等等，看看我能记住多少位圆周率。我大概在六年级时学的。好的。3.141592653589793238462643332795028419716939993。这就是我所知道的全部了。
Given that it goes on infinitely long, that's not very much. Oh, no, I'm kidding, it's not. The moment reveals something about William. He likes to see how far he can push himself. It's reflected in everything he does. He plays with a professional symphony orchestra. He's won awards for economics and physics. He plays with a professional symphony orchestra, he's won awards for economics and physics. He plays competitive golf.
考虑到它是无限长的，这并不算多。哦，不，我开玩笑的，确实不多。这一刻揭示了威廉的一些特质。他喜欢看自己能走多远。这反映在他所做的一切中。他与专业交响乐团一起演奏。他获得过经济学和物理学奖项。他与专业交响乐团一起演奏，他获得过经济学和物理学奖项。他参加竞技高尔夫比赛。
His list of achievements is long, but that list got tossed out when the mistake he made undid everything. We're going to tell you about that mistake, but first it's important to understand something about Williams upbringing. He grew up in a small city in Pennsylvania. And it's kind of in the middle of nowhere. He was, as his father Jeffrey tells me, an exceptionally kind and gentle child. My wife, when he was born, and for the first years of his life, always referred to him as
他的成就清单很长，但当他犯下的那个错误毁掉一切时，那份清单就被抛弃了。我们将告诉你那个错误，但首先，了解一些关于威廉的成长背景很重要。他在宾夕法尼亚州的一个小城市长大。那里有点与世隔绝。正如他父亲杰弗里告诉我的，他是一个异常善良和温柔的孩子。我妻子在他出生时，以及他生命的最初几年，总是称他为
sweet William, because his disposition was so incredibly sweet. William's family isn't wealthy, but he had plenty of advantages. Old home videos show what seems like a pretty idyllic childhood. There's one of William running to home base in Little League. Another of him when he's just eight, sitting in the cockpit of a small plane. Okay William, what do you do? We're round out there a bit and then we came in. And there's one when he's eleven, recounting for his dad every shot he made on an 18-hole golf course. The first one I had a little birdie putt, I missed it, second hole.
“甜心威廉”，因为他的性格实在是太甜了。威廉的家庭并不富裕，但他拥有很多优势。旧的家庭录像显示了一个看起来相当田园诗般的童年。有一个威廉在小联盟比赛中跑向本垒的镜头。另一个是他八岁时，坐在小型飞机驾驶舱里的镜头。好的威廉，你做了什么？我们在那里转了一圈，然后就进来了。还有一个是他十一岁时，向他爸爸讲述他在18洞高尔夫球场上打出的每一杆。第一个我有一个小鸟球推杆，我错过了，第二个洞。
I hit a sand wedge and do a couple of feet and saved porn, and then three I failed to get up and down. By high school, he was playing with a local symphony orchestra. He was getting noticed. William put the same energy into his studies. He had an epiphany one day in a sophomore year of high school during AP Physics. The class was studying momentum or the work energy theorem he can't quite remember, and he began to see connections he hadn't seen before. You know these are ideas that if you first look at them they're kind of crazy, but you do the math and you convince yourself of it and you think about
我用沙坑杆打了几英尺，保住了标准杆，然后第三个洞我没能一切一推。到高中时，他已经在当地交响乐团演奏了。他开始受到关注。威廉把同样的精力投入到学习中。高二那年，他在AP物理课上突然顿悟了。班级当时正在学习动量或功-能定理，他记不太清了，但他开始看到以前没发现的联系。你知道，这些想法如果你第一次看它们，会觉得有点疯狂，但你做了数学计算，说服了自己，并且思考
it, you think about it hard, and you realize that they make total sense in their second nature, and when you arrive at that point, that's just so satisfying to me. More than anything, William says he loves moments of epiphany when everything becomes clear. If you haven't picked up on this already, I like William. I like him not because of his math skills or his violin playing, but because of a single quality that cuts across different domains in his life. William takes genuine pleasure in ideas and learning. When you combine that with drive and determination,
它，你努力思考它，你意识到它们完全讲得通，而且是第二天性，当你达到那个点时，对我来说真是太满足了。威廉说，他最喜欢一切变得清晰的顿悟时刻。如果你还没发现，我喜欢威廉。我喜欢他不是因为他的数学技能或小提琴演奏，而是因为一种贯穿他生活不同领域的品质。威廉从思想和学习中获得真正的快乐。当你把这一点与动力和决心结合起来时，
it's a pretty special combination. I tag along as he goes to practice at a nearby golf course. We're standing on a hill. William pulls out a club and takes a few practice swings. So this is a three wood. This is actually my coach's three wood. He studies the club and concentrates on a ball in front of him. If I hit this wall, she gets to the green.
这是一个非常特别的组合。我跟着他去附近的高尔夫球场练习。我们站在一个小山坡上。威廉拿出一根球杆，做了几次练习挥杆。这是三号木。这其实是我教练的三号木。他研究着球杆，专注于面前的球。如果我打中这个球，它就能上果岭。
The green he's aiming for is a tiny speck across a road on top of another far off hill. After he hits the ball, I lose sight of it, but William seems to know where it's gone. So I have a general idea that this hole is about to give her take 270 yards long, so I should be, you know, not that far from the green. He's right. Three more strokes, and the ball is in the hole for par. Golf for William has lots in common with the violin. Both are for challenge, both draw on individual effort, on practice. Golf has also done something else for William.
他瞄准的果岭是穿过马路、在另一座遥远山丘顶上的一个小点。他击球后，我失去了球的踪迹，但威廉似乎知道它去了哪里。所以我大概知道这个洞大约是270码长，所以我应该，你知道，离果岭不远。他是对的。再打三杆，球就进了洞，保住了标准杆。对威廉来说，高尔夫与小提琴有很多共同点。两者都是挑战，两者都依赖个人努力和练习。高尔夫还为威廉做了另一件事。
It's given him insight into taking responsibility for the broken pieces of his life. When you're playing golf, you hit a ball in the trees. You know, you hit it there, it's on you. And you can be upset about that all you want, but it doesn't change the fact that the ball is in the trees, and you still have to get that ball in the hole. So now you have to treat it as if your ball was always in the trees, and you just have to figure out the best shot to hit from there,
它让他洞察到要为自己破碎的生活片段承担责任。当你打高尔夫时，你把球打进了树林。你知道，是你把它打到那里的，责任在你。你可以为此感到沮丧，但这并不能改变球在树林里的事实，你仍然必须把球打进洞里。所以现在你必须把它当作你的球一直就在树林里一样对待，你只需要找出从那里打出的最好一杆，
and see what the best score you can make of it is. That's what William is doing now, figuring out how to move on from the mistake he made and all the loss that followed. He says he's choosing a path of complete honesty and that's why he's decided to tell us what happened. In the fall of 2016, William was starting his senior year of high school and thinking hard about college. He wanted a college that valued learning for learning sake, for the joy that came with epiphanies. He was less interested in a college that merely sought to prepare him for employment.
看看你能打出的最好成绩是多少。这就是威廉现在正在做的事情，弄清楚如何从他犯下的错误以及随之而来的所有损失中走出来。他说他选择了完全诚实的道路，这就是为什么他决定告诉我们发生了什么。2016年秋天，威廉开始了他的高中最后一年，并认真考虑大学问题。他想要一所重视为学习而学习、重视顿悟带来的快乐的大学。他不太感兴趣那种仅仅寻求为就业做准备的大学。
And because he's William and because he loves a challenge, he decided to go for it, to try for Harvard. I had kind of figured that I didn't have that great of a shot of being accepted. William felt he wasn't in the same league as kids who get into Harvard. He assumed most kids who made it were nationally recognized in some way. So I didn't have the opportunities to do great research at great universities in high school still or doing really cool projects for science fairs like national science fairs. Never heard of like the international math Olympiad or international physics Olympiad. Never heard of these things. So I kind of figured where I was at,
而且因为他是威廉，因为他喜欢挑战，他决定放手一搏，尝试申请哈佛。我当时觉得我被录取的几率并不大。威廉觉得他不像那些能进哈佛的孩子那样处于同一个水平。他认为大多数能进去的孩子在某种程度上都是全国知名的。所以我没有机会在高中时在伟大的大学做伟大的研究，或者为科学博览会做很酷的项目，比如全国科学博览会。从没听说过国际数学奥林匹克或国际物理奥林匹克。从没听说过这些东西。所以我大概觉得以我的水平，
if I got in, it would just be because they liked me for some reason, and what are the chances of that? William applied early action to Harvard, meaning he would hear back from the school by mid-December. If he didn't get in, he would still have time to apply to other schools. On Harvard's announcement day, William was home with a friend. The decision was due at 5pm.
如果我被录取了，那只是因为他们出于某种原因喜欢我，而那样的几率有多大呢？威廉提前申请了哈佛，这意味着他会在12月中旬收到学校的回复。如果他没被录取，他还有时间申请其他学校。在哈佛的放榜日，威廉和朋友在家。决定在下午5点公布。
And we were just hanging out. We had been playing ping pong downstairs in my basement for a couple hours just to kill time. At 5 o'clock, really opened his computer. About 505 or so something showed up and it it said it was a new form that said admitted students reply form. It was confusing but seemed like a good sign. And then about 520 I want to say the actual letter that said congratulations popped up. There was more good news. I was gonna be going to my top choice dream school
我们当时就在那儿闲逛。我们在地下室打了几个小时乒乓球来打发时间。5点钟，威廉打开了他的电脑。大约5点05分左右，出现了一些东西，上面写着是一个新表格，写着“录取学生回复表”。这很令人困惑，但似乎是个好兆头。然后大约5点20分，我想说，那封写着“祝贺”的正式信件弹了出来。还有更多好消息。我将要去我首选的梦想学校，
and I got a letter saying that my financial aid package was like so great that I would be able to go to college and not have to take on debt. It's worth taking a moment to think about what Williams acceptance to Harvard meant. More Nobel Prize winners are associated with Harvard than any other university in the world. Every member of the US Supreme Court attended law school at Harvard or Yale. The university's endowment is larger than the GDP of more than half the countries on the planet.
而且我收到一封信说我的经济援助方案非常好，以至于我能够上大学而不必背负债务。值得花点时间思考一下威廉被哈佛录取意味着什么。与哈佛大学相关的诺贝尔奖得主比世界上任何其他大学都多。美国最高法院的每一位成员都曾就读于哈佛或耶鲁法学院。该大学的捐赠基金比地球上超过一半国家的GDP还要大。
Elite schools have come in for a lot of criticism lately, but there's little doubt why they are elite. They give their students a golden key to unlock every conceivable door. The recent college admissions scandal where wealthy parents paid bribes to get their children into top schools has put a price tag on the value of these golden keys. One family offered six and a half million dollars for a spot at Stanford. For a kid from a middle-class family in rural Pennsylvania, it was invited by the Harvard admissions office to join the official class of 2021 Facebook group.
精英学校最近受到了很多批评，但毫无疑问它们为什么是精英。它们给了学生一把金钥匙来打开每一扇可以想象的门。最近的大学招生丑闻中，富有的父母支付贿赂让孩子进入顶尖学校，这给这些金钥匙贴上了价格标签。一个家庭为斯坦福大学的一个名额提供了650万美元。对于一个来自宾夕法尼亚州农村中产阶级家庭的孩子来说，他被哈佛招生办公室邀请加入2021届官方Facebook群组。
He signed on, started to get to know his future classmates. There were the typical introductions that people did. Personal introductions usually a couple paragraphs long. I think this happens in just about every class, Facebook page for smaller class size universities and colleges. So you get to know people in that way and you comment on their stuff and maybe message them. William was blown away by the people he met. I was just so impressed by everything that they'd done the way they carried themselves. I was so impressed with it.
他登录了，开始了解他未来的同学。人们做了典型的自我介绍。个人介绍通常有几段长。我想这几乎发生在每一届大学的Facebook页面上，对于规模较小的大学和学院也是如此。所以你以那种方式了解人们，你评论他们的东西，也许给他们发消息。威廉被他遇到的人惊呆了。我对他们所做的一切、他们的举止印象深刻。我对此印象非常深刻。
I was a little bit intimidated, a little bit, but mostly just in awe of like, wow, these are all great people I'm looking at. William felt that all the kids on the Facebook group were incredibly accomplished. They were superstars from all over the world. He keenly felt the need to find his place among them. He was going through an age-old experience, but with a high octane twist. In the past, ice-breaking introductions of freshman year were made in person at social gatherings
我有点被吓到了，有一点，但更多的是敬畏，就像，哇，我看到的这些人都是很棒的人。威廉觉得Facebook群组里的所有孩子都非常有成就。他们是来自世界各地的超级明星。他敏锐地感到需要在他们中间找到自己的位置。他正在经历一种古老的体验，但带有一种高辛烷值的转折。过去，大一新生的破冰介绍是在社交聚会上亲自进行的，
on campus. Now they were happening in the months before school even started in the parallel universe that is social media. William joined several group chats. I joined a math group chat. I joined a economics and political science group chat. I joined a general group chat that was on group me. At first William says, there was tons of excitement and messaging and getting to know each other,
在校园里。现在，它们在学校开学前几个月就在社交媒体这个平行宇宙中发生了。威廉加入了几个群聊。我加入了一个数学群聊。我加入了一个经济学和政治学群聊。我加入了一个在GroupMe上的通用群聊。起初，威廉说，有很多兴奋和交流，互相了解，
but then it slowed down until the following spring. That's when the regular admission students joined in. Suddenly, there was a new burst of energy. admission students joined in. Suddenly, there was a new burst of energy. William got back into it and in late March, he joined a private chat he found through the Harvard Facebook page. It was a group chat about meme culture. For those who aren't familiar with memes, these are images, sometimes with a caption, that often juxtapose unrelated concepts, like putting the tourist of death in the JFK modicate, or a picture of a volcano exploding in the context of a family quarrel. Often it's the incongruity of these juxtapositions that gives
但后来它慢了下来，直到第二年春天。那是常规录取学生加入的时候。突然间，出现了一股新的能量。威廉重新投入其中，在3月下旬，他加入了一个通过哈佛Facebook页面找到的私人聊天群。这是一个关于模因文化的群聊。对于那些不熟悉模因的人来说，这些是图像，有时带有标题，通常将不相关的概念并置，比如把“死亡游客”放进肯尼迪的车队里，或者在家庭争吵的背景下放一张火山爆发的照片。通常正是这些并置的不协调感赋予了
memes their humor and their power as social commentary. Memes are also a way to telegraph, you and I are part of the same in group. We understand the same cultural references. William says at first, the memes were just banter. It was a little bit immature, just wacky more than anything else. But then a few people started sending, edg or memes.
模因它们的幽默感和作为社会评论的力量。模因也是一种传达“你和我属于同一个圈子”的方式。我们理解同样的文化参考。威廉说起初，这些模因只是调侃。它有点不成熟，更多的是古怪。但后来几个人开始发送更前卫的模因。
Edgy meaning like, offensive I guess? Eventually, the students sending edgy memes broke off and formed a new private group chat. They set up a rule. You had to first post an edgy meme to the bigger meme chat group in order to be admitted to the bigger meme chat group in order to be admitted to the subgroup. It eventually evolved into basically a contest of who could send the Egeost meme. William, of course, loves challenges. He started hunting for the Egeost of Egeem memes. It was kind of interesting to see it evolve from what it originally was, which was just being sort of wacky, into just straight into the depths of society and the worst things that society has to offer.
“前卫”意味着，冒犯性的，我想？最终，发送前卫模因的学生分出来，组建了一个新的私人聊天群。他们制定了一条规则。你必须先向更大的模因聊天群发布一个前卫模因，才能被允许进入子群组。它最终演变成了一场关于谁能发送最前卫模因的竞赛。威廉当然喜欢挑战。他开始寻找最前卫的模因。看到它从最初的样子——仅仅是有点古怪——演变成直接深入社会最糟糕的一面，这很有趣。
Like what? Well, there were definitely memes made about the Holocaust, Well, there were definitely memes made about the Holocaust, about the scandal and Catholicism of, you know, young boys and priests. Yeah, it was a lot of this stuff that's like, you don't want to touch in like normal everyday conversation unless you're condemning it. I asked William why people would send these memes to each other. His answer? They're funny. And the reason that they're funny and they get you to laugh is in part because they walk so close to the line.
比如什么？嗯，肯定有关于大屠杀的模因，关于天主教中年轻男孩和神职人员的丑闻。是的，有很多这种东西，就像，你不想在正常的日常对话中触碰它，除非你在谴责它。我问威廉为什么人们会互相发送这些模因。他的回答？它们很有趣。它们之所以有趣并让你发笑，部分原因是因为它们走得离底线太近了。
You know, now it's a different kind of funny because it comes with this weight of like, wow, our society is really terrible. And it's the shock value. It's the fact that somebody's willing to say that. That's just so outrageous. And you understand with each other that you're not being serious and these aren't your exact thoughts, right? That's part of what makes it a meme. It was like the social media version of a comedy club. Joking about what a bigot might say can be a way to expose bigotry. The more shocking the joke, the bigger the laughs. One of the things that we had in the chat was you'd send a fire emoji, you know, just
你知道，现在这是一种不同类型的有趣，因为它带有这种沉重感，就像，哇，我们的社会真的很糟糕。而且是那种冲击力。事实是有人愿意那样说。这太离谱了。而且你们互相理解你们不是认真的，这些不是你们真实的想法，对吧？这就是让它成为模因的一部分。这就像是喜剧俱乐部的社交媒体版本。拿偏执狂可能会说的话开玩笑可以成为揭露偏执的一种方式。笑话越令人震惊，笑声就越大。我们在聊天群里做的一件事就是你会发送一个火焰表情符号，你知道，只是
to say, oh, that's fire, that's something that's, I guess, very familiar to young people. It's a sort of slang, but fire, just meaning, like, that's gold, that's great stuff right there. So we'd send, like, fire emojis. So you could tell when people like to meme by how many fire emojis you saw after it and how many people would go OMG LOL right. William says he sent about 10 memes over the span of a couple of weeks. They varied in edginess or as William says in dankness. He gives this example of one of the milder ones. So like two meme numbers, I guess, are like 420 and 69. 420 is like talking about smoking marijuana,
为了说，哦，那很火，那是某种，我想，年轻人非常熟悉的东西。这是一种俚语，但“火”，只是意味着，就像，那是金子，那是好东西。所以我们会发送，比如，火焰表情符号。所以你可以通过它后面看到的火焰表情符号的数量以及有多少人会发“OMG LOL”来判断人们是否喜欢这个模因。威廉说他在几周内发送了大约10个模因。它们的“前卫”程度，或者像威廉说的“潮”度各不相同。他给出了一个较温和的例子。所以比如两个模因数字，我想是420和69。420就像是在谈论吸食大麻，
and 69 is like a sexual position. So I think I made a meme that was me typing in 420 to the 69th power into my calculator, and then the calculator returned like error overload. And I turned it into a meme that said like error overload of dankness, right? Dank being like a dank meme, like great meme. William also sent two memes that were far worse. He still remembers the day he did it.
而69就像是一种性姿势。所以我认为我制作了一个模因，是我在计算器上输入420的69次方，然后计算器返回了类似“错误过载”的信息。我把它变成了一个模因，上面写着类似“潮度过载”，对吧？“潮”就像是一个潮模因，就像很棒的模因。威廉还发送了两个糟糕得多的模因。他仍然记得他做这件事的那一天。
He was with a friend, a fellow musician, driving down the highway. They were headed to a future business leaders of America, state competition. And we were listening to rock modernov's second piano concerto in the car. The two teenagers were having a non-stop meandering conversation over the merits of Rock Maneinov's Piano Concerto 2 versus Rock Maneinov's Piano Concerto 3. a concerto 3. William would occasionally glance at his phone to see the latest meme. If there was a new message that popped up, I'd like look at it and tell him what it was and he'd laugh and I'd laugh.
他和一位朋友，也是一位音乐家，正开车在高速公路上。他们正前往一场美国未来商业领袖州级竞赛。我们在车里听着拉赫玛尼诺夫的第二钢琴协奏曲。两个青少年在车里进行着关于拉赫玛尼诺夫钢琴协奏曲2号与3号优劣的持续不断的漫谈。威廉偶尔会看一眼手机查看最新的模因。如果有新消息弹出来，我会看一眼并告诉他那是什么，他会笑，我也会笑。
Meanwhile, William was also googling for memes that he could post. He went on sites that contained controversial memes. He chose one. It was a picture of a pregnant woman's stomach and it had like a loading bar across it and it said loading 75%. And then right below that was a picture of a child with birth defects that said error. That's just like, it's pretty offensive. A little while later, on the same drive, he sent another meme.
与此同时，威廉也在谷歌搜索他可以发布的模因。他去了包含争议性模因的网站。他选了一个。那是一张孕妇肚子的照片，上面有一个加载条，写着“加载75%”。然后就在那下面是一张有出生缺陷的孩子照片，写着“错误”。那真的，非常冒犯。过了一会儿，在同一段车程中，他又发了另一个模因。
So this is definitely the worst one that I sent. Just, you know, not good. Now, I'm going to preface this by saying it still requires the same understanding and siding with the victim, but it's just like too far on that offensiveness scale. So it was a picture of a sloth whispering into a woman's ear, and it said, she put me in the friend zone, so I put her in the rape zone. I don't get it actually.
所以这绝对是我发送的最糟糕的一个。只是，你知道，不好。现在，我要先说明一下，这仍然需要同样的理解和站在受害者一边，但它在冒犯性量表上走得太远了。所以那是一张树懒在女人耳边低语的照片，上面写着：“她把我放进了朋友区，所以我把她放进了强奸区。”我其实没看懂。
What does that mean? The sloth is supposed to be a guy and it's basically portraying guys or at least this type of guy as like a sloth, like a bad type of person, sneaky, slimy, you don't want to mess with him type person. So it's still saying that like people like this are bad people. That's still embedded in the meme. But it's not as clear. You see, like you didn't get the sloth when I first explained it. And that's part of the problem with that meme in particular. it's not clear enough, especially for the weight of that issue because like, you know, this throws up red flags to colleges because it's
那是什么意思？树懒被设定为一个男人，它基本上是在描绘男人，或者至少是这种类型的男人，像树懒一样，像一种坏人，鬼鬼祟祟、卑鄙，你不想惹的那种人。所以它仍然是在说像这样的人是坏人。这仍然嵌入在模因中。但它不那么清晰。你看，就像你第一次解释时没看懂树懒一样。这就是那个特定模因的问题所在。它不够清晰，特别是对于那个问题的严重性而言，因为，你知道，这给大学敲响了警钟，因为这是
a big problem on college campuses. So they don't want someone who's like too free in talking about this and seems comfortable with rape on their campus, right? So that's why it's extra problematic. So when you were sending these, what were you aiming to get from the group? What do you think was going to come from them? I was trying to make friends. I was nervous about going to college and not really having friends. It, I guess it goes back to a lack of self confidence on my part almost because I didn't feel like I was adequate to be friends with these people
大学校园里的一个大问题。所以他们不想要一个在谈论这个问题时太随意，并且似乎对校园里的强奸感到自在的人，对吧？所以这就是它格外成问题的原因。所以当你发送这些时，你从群组里想得到什么？你认为会从中得到什么？我是在试图交朋友。我对自己要上大学却没真正交到朋友感到紧张。这，我想这几乎可以追溯到我个人缺乏自信，因为我觉得我不够格和这些人做朋友，
without kind of elevating myself to that level of memory. There's really two ways to sort of interpret what happened. I mean, on the one hand, you're a good student, you're into music, you're into sports, you're well loved by the community, you get into Harvard, you're a kid from a small town, you've made good, you make a boneheaded mistake, that's one narrative. The other narrative is, look, you come from a family of privilege, you got into one of the top schools, certainly your privilege probably helped you along the way in ways big and small, and you abuse that privilege by saying things about people who in some ways were much weaker than you. Which version of that is correct? I would like to think the first version and the reason I say that is because I know myself and my
除非通过那种模因提升自己到那个水平。对于发生的事情，实际上有两种解读方式。一方面，你是一个好学生，你喜欢音乐，你喜欢运动，你深受社区喜爱，你进了哈佛，你是一个来自小镇的孩子，你成功了，你犯了一个愚蠢的错误，这是一个叙事。另一个叙事是，看，你来自一个特权家庭，你进入了顶尖学校之一，当然你的特权可能在很大程度上帮助了你，而你通过说一些关于在某些方面比你弱得多的人的话来滥用这种特权。哪个版本是正确的？我愿意认为是第一个版本，我这样说的原因是，因为我了解我自己和我的
intentions and the second version of that story is very much at odds with who I am and what my intentions were. The phrase abuse your privilege, kind of implies some sort of intent. And I think that couldn't be further from the truth because when I look introspectively at my own thoughts, the way I treat other people, I don't think that's me. William says he understood even at the time that the meme group chat was going too far. And the way I know that is before I would send one of the crazy ones, I'd get a sort of pit in my stomach as well. I don't know what to call it. You know that bad feeling when you know you're about to do something stupid.
意图，而那个故事的第二个版本与我是谁以及我的意图非常不符。“滥用你的特权”这个短语，隐含着某种意图。我认为这离事实太远了，因为当我内省自己的想法、我对待他人的方式时，我不认为那是真正的我。威廉说他当时就明白模因聊天群做得太过分了。我知道这一点是因为在我发送那些疯狂的模因之一之前，我的胃里也会有一种不舒服的感觉。我不知道该怎么称呼它。你知道那种当你明知自己要做蠢事时的那种糟糕感觉。
You're about to do something bad. I got that. And the part about what I did that messes me up the most, I guess, is the fact that I didn't listen to that, and I just went ahead and hit Sand anyway. He hit Sand anyway, and then the memes were off. They could never be taken back. It's now April, a couple weeks after William sent the memes.
你要做坏事了。我有那种感觉。而关于我所做的事情中最让我难受的部分，我想，是事实是我没有听从那种感觉，我还是直接点击了发送。他还是点击了发送，然后模因就发出去了。它们永远无法撤回。现在是四月，威廉发送模因几周后。
He's in class at the end of his senior year of high school, working on a physics exam. His phone starts to vibrate. And it's buzzing. I'm like, someone's calling me, but I'll ignore it. And it buzzes again, keeps buzzing. I keep letting it go. And I keep getting this call like probably four or five six times Finally he asked his teacher if he can answer it and he's like, yeah sure go for it because he's super relaxed
他在高中最后一年的一节课上，正在做物理考试。他的手机开始震动。它在嗡嗡响。我想，有人在给我打电话，但我会忽略它。它又响了，一直响。我一直不理它。我可能接到了四五六次这样的电话。最后他问老师他能不能接，老师说，是的，当然，去吧，因为他非常放松。
You know we've known each other for a few years now, so he trusts me So I pick it up and it's one of my friends from the chat is like Oh my god, Will like know, check your email, they know. They was Harvard. In William's inbox was a note from Harvard admissions. William read it to me that day I met with him.
你知道我们已经认识几年了，所以他信任我。所以我接了，是聊天群里的一个朋友，他说：“天哪，威尔，你知道，检查你的电子邮件，他们知道了。”他们指的是哈佛。在威廉的收件箱里，有一封来自哈佛招生办的信。威廉那天我见到他时读给我听了。
So this was April 11th, 2017 at 2.04 pm. It's a dear William. It is unfortunate that I have to reach out about this situation. The admissions committee was disappointed to learn that several students in a private group chat for the class of 2021 were sending messages that contained offensive messages and graphics. As we understand, you are among the members contributing such material to this chat, we are asking that you submit a statement by tomorrow at noon to explain your contributions and actions for discussion with the admissions committee. William was devastated, but in the stun shock that followed, he composed a response. So dear Harvard admissions, I'm incredibly sorry for and deeply regret my irresponsible
所以这是2017年4月11日下午2点04分。亲爱的威廉。很遗憾我必须就这种情况与你联系。招生委员会得知2021届的一些学生在一个私人聊天群中发送包含冒犯性信息和图形的消息，感到非常失望。据我们了解，你是向该聊天群贡献此类材料的成员之一，我们要求你在明天中午之前提交一份声明，以解释你的贡献和行为，以便招生委员会讨论。威廉崩溃了，但在随后的震惊中，他写了一份回复。亲爱的哈佛招生办，我非常抱歉，并对我参与在非官方模因聊天群中进行煽动性行为的轻率决定深感后悔。我最初加入聊天群是希望结识未来的朋友，并与2021届的其他成员相处融洽，希望能融入一个群体。威廉试图解释事情是如何失控的。不幸的是，在屏幕后面、在快节奏的环境中，表现得不像自己，说出一些我在日常生活中永远不会说甚至不会想的话，实在是太容易了。几天后，哈佛要求提供更多信息，
decision to participate in engaging in flammatory behavior on the unofficial meme group chat. I originally joined the group chat in hopes of meeting future friends and becoming comfortable with the other members of the class of 2021, hoping to fit in with a group. William tried to explain how things had spiraled. Unfortunately, it's far too easy to act out of character behind a screen in a fast-paced setting and to say things that I would never say or even think of during the course of everyday life. A few days later, Harvard asked for more information,
包括模因的图像。请在周一中午之前提供一份关于你在其中所扮演角色的完整解释，并附上你每一项贡献的标识。这封信还告诉他，他不被欢迎参加“Visitas”，即录取学生的年度聚会。由于你的录取状态目前正在审查中，请不要计划参加即将到来的校园Visitas周末。谢谢，已删除。复活节周日，在收到第二封信后，威廉终于告诉了他爸爸发生了什么事。
including images of the memes. Please provide no later than noon Monday a full explanation of your role with identifications of each of your contributions there too. The letter also told him he was not welcome at Visitas, the annual gathering of admitted students. As your admission status is presently under review, please do not plan on attending the upcoming Visitas Weekend on campus. Thank you, is presently under review, please do not plan on attending the upcoming visit-hoss weekend on campus. Thank you, Redacted. On Easter Sunday, after that second note, William finally told his dad what was going on.
嗯，他告诉我，你知道，我有麻烦了。我的意思是，你知道，哈佛正在调查我，这是复活节周日。杰弗里感到措手不及。我做梦也没想到会发生这种事。我的意思是，我们的太阳系有很小的几率会被某种伽马射线暴摧毁，我想他们是这么叫的。你知道，那至少我还会预料到
Well, he told me, you know, I'm in trouble. I mean, you know, Harvards investigating me for this, and this was Easter Sunday. Jeffrey felt blindsided. I never saw this coming in a million years. I mean, there's a small chance that our solar system could be blasted out of existence by some gamma ray burst, I think they call it. You know, that at least I would expect
概率非常非常小。这比那还小。我的意思是，我甚至不知道这种事情是可能的。他走进楼下。我妻子正用一把大刀切蔬菜，我对她说，你知道，放下刀，坐下。我必须告诉你一些非常沉重的事情。我告诉了她，她泪流满面，因为她的第一个念头是，这些孩子中有一个会自杀。所以那天晚上的复活节晚餐很安静。没有人说任何话？
with very, very small probability. This was less than that. I mean, I didn't even know this kind of thing was possible. He walked downstairs. My wife was cutting vegetables with a big knife, and I said to her, you know, put the knife down, sit down. I've got to tell you something really heavy. And I told her and she burst into tears because her first thought was, one of these kids is gonna commit suicide. So Easter dinner that night was silent. No one said anything at all?
我想说了大约两句话。就像我想我能准确数出两句话。一句说，比如，你能把黄油递给我吗？那是我的妈妈在对我爸爸说话。然后我妈妈也说，嗯，谢谢你，杰弗里。这非常好。威尔，当你和你的父母坐在桌边时，你脑子里在想什么？呃，我低着头。
I think about two sentences were said. Like I think I can count exactly two sentences. One said, like, can you pass me the butter? And that was my mom addressing my dad. And then my mom also said, well, thank you, Jeffrey. This was very good. And what went through your mind as you were sitting at the table, Will, with your two parents? Uh, I kept my head down.
我盯着桌子的边缘，我非常封闭。我记得我当时的感觉，我的肩膀有点缩着，驼着背。我的背驼着。我的手放在膝盖之间，除了我吃东西的时候，我非常专注于不说什么。那只是那种你想钻进洞里的时刻之一。你觉得你让父母失望了吗？是的，但我主要担心的是我绝对让自己失望了。我绝对知道我可能浪费了，你知道，给予我的最大机会。
I was like staring at the edge of the table and I was very closed off. I can remember the way I felt my shoulders were kind of closed in hunched. My back was hunched. My hands were kind of between my knees except when I was going into eat something and I was pretty intent on not really saying anything. It was just one of those moments where you just, you want to crawl in a hole. Did you feel you'd let your parents down? Yeah, but my primary concern was that I definitely let myself down. I definitely knew that there's a chance I'd just squandered, you know, the greatest opportunity
九天来，威廉什么也没听到。Visitas来了又走了。然后在一个周三，当他开车沿15号公路经过麦当劳时，他的手机响了。是之前打过电话的同一个朋友。他听起来状态很糟。他告诉威廉检查他的电子邮件。
that had been given to me. For nine days, William heard nothing. Visitas came and went. And then on a Wednesday, as he was driving south on Route 15 past the McDonald's, his phone buzzed. It was the same friend who had called before. He sounded in bad shape. He told William to check his email.
好的，上面写着，我写信是为了跟进我们之前的沟通。招生委员会重新评估了你的申请。我很遗憾地通知你，它撤回了对你哈佛学院的录取通知。如你所知，哈佛学院保留在各种条件下撤回录取通知的权利，包括如果你参与或曾经参与质疑你的诚实、成熟度或道德品质的行为。我可以很快读出那部分，因为我没背下来。经过仔细和广泛的考虑和讨论，委员会做出了撤回录取通知的艰难决定。
Okay, so it said, I write to follow up on our earlier communications. The Committee on Admissions has re-evaluated your application. I am very sorry to inform you that it is withdrawing its offer to you of admission to Harvard College. As you are aware, Harvard College reserves the right to withdraw an offer of admission under various conditions, including if you engage or have engaged in behavior that brings into question, you're honesty, maturity maturity or moral character. I can read that part really fast because I haven't memorized. After careful and extensive consideration and discussion the committee made the difficult decision to withdraw the offer of admission
请注意，此决定是最终决定。此决定是最终决定。威廉在路边他的车里坐了一会儿。在接下来的几周里，当他结束高中学业时，他不得不面对那些认为他是明星的朋友和老师。他告诉了他的校长发生了什么事。消息开始传出。威廉记得走进合唱团排练室，感觉到同学们的注视。他的舞伴给他发了一条短信，告诉他她不能和他一起去参加舞会，因为她妈妈不想让她和
please be aware that this decision is final. this decision is final. William sat for a while in his car on the side of the road. In the next weeks, as he finished up at high school, he had to face friends and teachers, who I thought he was a star. He told his principal what had happened. Wood started to get out. William remembers walking into choir rehearsal and feeling the stairs of his classmates. His prom date sent him a text, telling him she couldn't go to the dance with him, because her mom didn't want her going to prom with
一个会被学校开除的人一起去参加舞会。因为他提前申请了哈佛并被录取了，他没有申请任何其他学校。现在已经太晚了。在接下来的一年里，他不得不留在宾夕法尼亚州中部那个小城市，而他所有的朋友都去上大学了。一天晚上，威廉在高尔夫球场待到日落很久之后。天太黑了，他说他能看到他击球时火花飞溅。我最后只是躺在练习场的地上。天够黑了。
someone who would get kicked out of school. Because he had applied early action to Harvard and gotten in, he hadn't applied to any other schools. It was now too late. For the next year, he would have to stay behind in his little city in the middle of Pennsylvania, while all his friends went off to college. One night, William stayed long past sunset at the golf course. It was so dark he says he could see sparks fly when he hit the ball. I ended up just lying down on the ground out on the range. It was dark enough.
高尔夫球场上没有其他人。我记得躺在练习场上，我给几个我承诺过如果遇到麻烦就会打电话的人打了电话，和他们聊了聊，然后又在那里躺了大概半小时、45分钟，然后我开车回家，双手紧紧握着方向盘，全程都在告诉自己，不要冲进护栏，不要冲下悬崖，什么的。然后情况变得更糟了。六月，威廉的爸爸回忆说，哈佛的学生报纸《深红报》报道了这个故事。
There was nobody else at the golf course. And I just, I remember lying down on the range and I called a couple people that I promised I would call if I was ever having any trouble and talk to them and kept lying there for probably another half hour, 45 minutes, and then I drove home, white knuckles on the steering wheel, just telling myself the entire time like don't swerve into the barrier, don't swerve off the cliff, whatever. And then it got worse. of off the cliff, whatever. And then it got worse. In June, William's dad recalls, the Harvard student newspaper, the Crimson, broke the story
高尔夫球场上没有其他人。我记得我躺在练习场上，给几个我承诺过如果遇到困难就会联系的人打了电话，和他们聊了聊，然后又在那里躺了大概半小时到四十五分钟。之后我开车回家，双手紧紧握着方向盘，一路上都在对自己说，不要撞向护栏，不要冲下悬崖，诸如此类。后来情况变得更糟了。威廉的父亲回忆说，六月份，哈佛大学校报《克里姆森报》披露了这则新闻。
of the group of students who had been rescinded. And then within two hours, it was all over the world. My cousins in Europe were telling me it's on the BBC here, and of course it was New York Times, Boston Globe, NPR, Fox News, CNN, it was everywhere. Every year, Harvard accepts the best and the brightest. But some of the latest incoming freshmen have already been kicked out. The Harvard Crimson outlining the content of the memes.
在被撤销录取的学生群体中。两个小时内，这件事就传遍了全世界。我在欧洲的表亲告诉我，英国广播公司（BBC）报道了这件事，当然还有《纽约时报》、《波士顿环球报》、美国国家公共电台（NPR）、福克斯新闻、美国有线电视新闻网（CNN），到处都是。哈佛大学每年都会录取最优秀、最聪明的学生。但最近一些新生已经被开除了。《哈佛深红报》概述了这些表情包的内容。
Some sexually explicit others targeting at the... According to the Crimson, the group was called Harvard Memes for horny bourgeois teens. The university... And, you know, CNN had a headline that I really hated. It was like, Harvard rescinds bigoted students. And I wondered who, CNN, put the word bigoted in there. I mean, what did they know about this? William says that one of the ironies of the scandal
有些涉及性露骨内容，另一些则针对……据《哈佛克里姆森报》报道，该组织名为“哈佛色情资产阶级青少年表情包”。大学……你知道，CNN有一个我非常讨厌的标题。标题大概是“哈佛撤销了偏执学生的录取”。我很好奇，CNN，是谁把“偏执”这个词放进去的？我的意思是，他们对此了解多少？威廉说，这起丑闻的讽刺之处之一在于
was that the group of rescinded kids was even more diverse than the incoming class as a whole. Many of the memes most offensive to various groups were posted by students who were themselves members of those groups. It was almost like they were taking the most offensive things people say about people like them and using this pain as a form of currency to win favor with new friends. There was an Emmett Till meme. There was another one about lynching.
被撤销录取的学生群体甚至比整个新生班级更加多元化。许多对不同群体最具冒犯性的表情包，其实是由这些群体成员自己发布的。这几乎就像是他们把人们针对他们这类人所说的最冒犯的话拿来，将这种痛苦作为一种货币，用来博取新朋友的好感。其中有一个关于埃米特·蒂尔的表情包，还有一个关于私刑的。
They were both sent by an African American kid. What was the Emmett Till meme? It said, when your mom walks in on you mid-nut bust. So making a reference to masturbation. And it's the famous picture of Emmett Till, like the recovered body after he's been totally bludgeoned. And, you know, it's just not great, but it was a member of the African-American community sending that.
它们都是由一个非裔美国孩子发送的。那个埃米特·蒂尔（Emmett Till）的梗是什么意思？上面写着：当你妈在你自慰时突然走进来。所以这是在影射自慰。而配图是埃米特·蒂尔那张著名的照片，也就是他被彻底殴打致死后发现的遗体。你知道，这确实不太好，但发送那个梗的人是非裔美国人社区的一员。
There was also another one that said, when the Mexican kid hangs himself in this school bathroom, then it said, it's pinata time. That was sent by a Hispanic guy. There were also various memes dealing with the Holocaust mostly sent by a Jewish girl. Most of the memes about terrorists were sent by the person I know from Lebanon, who's seen suicide bombings in real life, like scene them happen. So if anyone's like justified to make a meme about that, you'd think, you know, it's them. We tried to independently confirm the content of the memes shared within this private Facebook group. There were elements of various memes that we could confirm, but most of the details in the story come from William himself.
还有另一个梗写着：当墨西哥孩子在学校厕所上吊时，然后写道：皮纳塔（pinata）时间到了。那是被一个西班牙裔的人发送的。还有各种关于大屠杀的梗，大多是由一个犹太女孩发送的。大多数关于恐怖分子的梗是由我认识的一个黎巴嫩人发送的，他曾在现实生活中见过自杀式炸弹袭击，是亲眼目睹的那种。所以如果有人有理由制作关于那个的梗，你会觉得，你知道，那个人就是他。我们试图独立核实这个私人Facebook群组中分享的梗的内容。我们可以确认各种梗的某些元素，但故事中的大部分细节都来自威廉本人。
Harvard has never released the names of the rescinded students and has talked to its policy of not discussing any admission decisions. In a statement, Rachel Dane, a university spokeswoman, only said Harvard reserved the right to rescind offers of admission to students who fail to graduate or didn't keep up their high school grades or, quote, engaged in behavior that brings into question their honesty, maturity or moral character. In other words, if you
哈佛大学从未公布过被撤销录取资格的学生名单，并表示其政策是不讨论任何录取决定。哈佛大学发言人瑞秋·戴恩（Rachel Dane）在一份声明中仅表示，哈佛保留撤销录取资格的权利，针对那些未能毕业、未能保持高中成绩，或者引用原文，从事了让人质疑其诚实、成熟度或道德品质的行为的学生。换句话说，如果你
didn't turn out to be the person Harvard thought you were, the university reserved the right to change its mind. William says everyone he knows who got kicked out struggled in different ways. Like there were students who were thinking, oh my god, my parents are going to kill me because they've been working in the background my whole life to set me up for this kind of success. And I, you know, I blew it and they're gonna, they're gonna be furious with me, but then there were other students who were really coming from nothing and this, there were students who like didn't know
如果最终没能成为哈佛所期望的那种人，校方保留改变主意的权利。威廉说他认识的每一个被开除的人，挣扎的方式各不相同。有的学生会想，天哪，我父母会杀了我的，因为他们为了让我取得这种成功，在我的一生中都在幕后默默付出。而我，你知道，我搞砸了，他们会非常愤怒。但也有一些学生确实是一无所有，还有一些学生甚至不知道
their dad and then right afterward I'm thinking of one kid in particular, he didn't know his dad at all and right after this happened his mom died. He didn't know his dad at all and right after this happened his mom died. For his part, William tried to do the best he could during his unwanted gap year. He played in the symphony. He enrolled in math and physics courses at a local college. He won a physics award. He worked part-time.
他们的父亲是谁。紧接着，我特别想到了一个孩子，他根本不知道自己的父亲是谁，而这件事发生后不久，他的母亲就去世了。他根本不知道自己的父亲是谁，而这件事发生后不久，他的母亲就去世了。就威廉而言，他在那段不情愿的间隔年里尽了最大努力。他参加了交响乐团，在当地一所大学选修了数学和物理课程，还获得了一个物理奖项，并做了兼职工作。
Slowly, the months passed. And then it was time to try again. William let every school he was applying to know exactly what he had done. And what I decided I was most comfortable with was telling people because I feel like that's something that admissions people would want to know. They would find it a very unpleasant surprise. So if there's something that they should know, I think I should tell them. In the fall of 2017, he submitted an early action application to Princeton. He felt he had a good shot. His interview went well and William believed he was a
时间就这样慢慢流逝。然后，又到了再次尝试的时候。威廉让他申请的每一所学校都知道他到底做了什么。我决定，最让我感到心安的做法就是告诉他们，因为我觉得这是招生人员想要了解的情况。如果他们发现这是一个非常不愉快的意外，那就不好了。所以如果这是他们应该知道的事情，我想我应该告诉他们。2017年秋天，他向普林斯顿大学提交了提前录取申请。他觉得自己的机会很大。面试进行得很顺利，威廉相信自己是一个
better, more well-rounded person than he'd been the year before. So December 13th, 2017, from Princeton University. Dear William, I am sorry to inform you that we were not able to admit you to Princeton University this year. The admissions process is difficult for students and families and we realize that you are likely to be disappointed with our decision. It was a flat rejection. Next, KMIT. I am very sorry to tell you that you were not admitted to the MIT class of 2022. And all in it went from Johns Hopkins.
比前一年更好、更全面的人。2017年12月13日，来自普林斯顿大学的回复：亲爱的威廉，很遗憾地通知你，我们今年无法录取你进入普林斯顿大学。招生过程对学生和家庭来说都很艰难，我们意识到你可能会对我们的决定感到失望。这是一次彻底的拒绝。接下来是麻省理工学院：很抱歉地通知你，你未被麻省理工学院2022届录取。随后，约翰霍普金斯大学也发来了拒信。
After a thorough review of your application. We regret to reinforce you Chicago. After much consideration, I regret to inform you that we, I am very sorry to let you know we were unable to offer you admission to Stanford. William had reapplied to Harvard and also to Yale, Columbia, and Brown universities. Jeffrey remembers what happened on the day. All those schools announced their decisions. The bleakest day, a year later, I remember
经过对你申请材料的全面审查，我们很遗憾……芝加哥大学：经过慎重考虑，我很遗憾地通知你……我很抱歉地告诉你，我们无法为你提供斯坦福大学的录取名额。威廉重新申请了哈佛，以及耶鲁、哥伦比亚和布朗大学。杰弗里记得那些学校宣布录取结果的那一天。那是最惨淡的一天，一年后，我记得
was on what they call all Ivy Day. It's when all the Ivy League colleges decide on the same day, you know, who they're taking. And I remember he got rejected by all of them a year later. And my wife and I immediately went to where he was in lab at the college to just show him that we were there for him. And he turned and he looked at us and the look on his face, it was the hardest thing I've ever had to see in my son. It was this look of utter despair.
是在所谓的“常春藤盟校放榜日”。那天所有的常春藤盟校都在同一天决定录取名单。我记得一年后他被所有这些学校拒绝了。我和我妻子立刻赶到他所在的大学实验室，只是为了让他知道我们支持他。他转过身看着我们，他脸上的表情是我这辈子见过儿子最痛苦的样子。那是一种彻底绝望的表情。
Now, it's not the end of the world to get rejected by the Ivy Leagues. There are plenty of excellent universities and colleges and community colleges across the country. And in the end, it wasn't a shutout. Of the 17 schools he deployed to, William was accepted to two, UCLA and Penn State. He was waitlisted at three. Eventually one of those waitless schools offered him a slot. William and his dad rushed to visit the campus. We were wandering around and there was something about an open house and it
现在，被常春藤盟校拒绝并不是世界末日。全国各地有许多优秀的大学、学院和社区学院。最终，他并没有被完全拒之门外。在他申请的17所学校中，威廉被两所录取，分别是加州大学洛杉矶分校和宾夕法尼亚州立大学。他在三所学校被列入候补名单。最终，其中一所候补学校给了他一个名额。威廉和他的父亲匆忙赶去参观校园。我们在校园里闲逛，正好赶上开放日，但
turned out we'd missed it and so I was very disappointed and then this professor just wandered in and said, can I help you? He looked like he was picking up something from a printer. And we said, well, we're visiting and will he master side by five o'clock? And he said, please come to my office. So we went to his office, and I just sat there too with them. He and will he mad this wonderful conversation
结果我们错过了，所以我非常失望。这时，一位教授走了过来，问我们是否需要帮助。他看起来像是刚从打印机那里拿了什么东西。我们说，我们是来参观的，想看看威廉能不能在五点前参观一下。他说，请到我的办公室来。于是我们去了他的办公室，我也和他们一起坐在那里。他和威廉进行了非常棒的交谈，
about physics and music and all kinds of things for about an hour? And it was just an amazing conversation. I was very impressed. He was giving us so much of his time. And then the moment that I'll never forget was at one point, he just gets out of his chair, he gets down on one knee, he puts his hands together, and he says, please come here. And then he just got back in his seat and kept on talking. And I thought, oh my God, that is the sweetest, most wonderful thing. I've, this whole year, I've got started to tear up now, but I just, it was amazing.
谈论物理、音乐和各种各样的事情，大约谈了一个小时。那真是一次令人惊叹的谈话。我印象非常深刻。他给了我们这么多时间。然后，我永远不会忘记的那一刻是，他突然从椅子上站起来，单膝跪地，双手合十，说，请到这里来。然后他又坐回座位，继续交谈。我想，天哪，这真是太贴心、太美妙了。这一整年，我现在又要流泪了，但这真的太棒了。
I love that guy. And I thought, you know, when I get back home, I'm going to write the chair of the physics department. And I'm going to say what a wonderful professor that guy was. apartment and I'm going to say what a wonderful professor that guy was and I got home and looked up at who this guy was and that was the chair of the physics department. I said, oh my God, you know, what a wonderful place. So anyway, as you can tell, I don't think I've gotten emotional about this since then, but I just want to thank that professor. And what do you think is evoking this feeling in you? What do you think that professor. And what do you think is evoking this feeling in you? What do you think that professor was doing? What was he communicating to William that makes you so moved? He was being good to my son.
我喜欢那个人。我想，等我回家后，我要写信给物理系主任。我要说那个人是一位多么出色的教授。当我回到家，查了一下那个人是谁，发现他竟然就是物理系主任。我说，天哪，这真是一个美妙的地方。总之，如你所见，从那以后我还没为这件事激动过，但我只是想感谢那位教授。你认为是什么唤起了你这种感觉？你认为那位教授在做什么？他在向威廉传达什么，让你如此感动？他在善待我的儿子。
When I met him, William had just finished his first year at college. He's doing well. But he still struggles with the what if. He's had a hard time letting go of what his life might have been like at Harvard. He says he doesn't blame the Harvard admissions office in any way. In fact, he says that if he was in their shoes, he probably would have made the same decision. He takes full responsibility for what he did. Like, I tell people when they meet me in a serious context, if I ever do something wrong, please tell me
当我见到他时，威廉刚读完大学一年级。他做得很好。但他仍然在纠结“如果当初”的问题。他很难放下如果他去了哈佛，生活会是什么样子。他说他一点也不责怪哈佛招生办。事实上，他说如果换作是他，他可能也会做出同样的决定。他对自己所做的事情承担全部责任。就像我告诉人们的那样，当他们在严肃的场合见到我时，如果我做错了什么，请告诉我，
and call me out for it, and I will look you in the eye, tell you I'm sorry, and that I'll do better next time it and I will look you in the eye, tell you I'm sorry and that I'll do better next time and I'll mean it. And that's something that I honestly believe that I've done a good job at committing myself to. William is still active on social media and despite all the trouble memes have caused him, he still likes them. When we were out on the golf course, he told me that during his freshman year, he couldn't
并指出我的错误，我会直视你的眼睛，告诉你我很抱歉，下次我会做得更好，而且我是真心的。这是我真心相信自己已经努力做到的事情。威廉在社交媒体上仍然很活跃，尽管表情包给他带来了所有的麻烦，但他仍然喜欢它们。当我们在高尔夫球场上时，他告诉我，在他大一的时候，他无法
resist signing up for a class he saw advertised on campus. It was about memes. One night at the meme class, an old friend of his was visiting. She happened to go to Harvard and was in the same class William would have been in had he not been kicked out. He invited her to the meme class. So walk in and I introduce her. I'm like, hey guys, this is my friend from Harvard. So we sit down. We're going through the class. The week's topic was college meme pages. But they threw in a slide about the Harvard meme scandal. They didn't know. They didn't know.
抗拒报名参加他在校园里看到的一门课程。那是关于表情包的。一天晚上，在表情包课上，他的一位老朋友来访。她恰好在哈佛上学，而且如果威廉没有被开除，他本也会在那门课上。他邀请她来参加表情包课。所以我们走进去，我介绍她。我说，嘿，伙计们，这是我在哈佛的朋友。我们坐下来。我们正在上课。那周的主题是大学表情包页面。但他们放了一张关于哈佛表情包丑闻的幻灯片。他们不知道。他们不知道。
And my friend from Harvard was there. And I had introduced her. And then they're like, oh yeah, you're from Harvard. Do you know anything about this? And she's like, oh, kind of. William finally fest up. I said, so remember at the beginning of the semester when I said, memes completely changed the course of my life. And then all their jobs dropped. They're like, do you want to teach the class right
而我那位来自哈佛的朋友也在那里。我已经介绍过她了。然后他们说，哦，对了，你是哈佛的。你知道这件事吗？她说，哦，略知一二。威廉终于坦白了。我说，还记得学期初我说过，表情包彻底改变了我的人生吗？然后他们所有人都惊呆了。他们说，你想现在就来教这门课吗？
now? When I first talked to Williams' father, Jeffrey, we ruminated on a puzzle. Nearly everything that everyone says on social media goes unnoticed. And everyone can see you're getting no traction. This can drive some of us to come up with the edgiest, funniest, hottest takes. Likes and retweets and fire emojis become currency, signaling our worth to those around us. Sometimes the things we post work and we become stars. Other times we we fall flat. Or worse, my joke sets off your rage. When this happens, it's no use saying
当我第一次和威廉的父亲杰弗里交谈时，我们思考了一个谜题。社交媒体上每个人说的几乎所有话都无人问津。每个人都能看到你没有任何反响。这可能会驱使我们中的一些人想出最前卫、最有趣、最热门的观点。点赞、转发和火焰表情符号成了货币，向周围的人标榜我们的价值。有时我们发布的内容奏效了，我们成了明星。其他时候，我们表现平平。或者更糟，我的笑话引发了你的愤怒。当这种情况发生时，说
there is even more terrible stuff online. There is only a price to pay. The things we post take on a life of their own. And they can be as permanent as a scar. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Laura Correll, Thomas Liu and Pat Shab, and edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen. We had original music composed by Ramteen Arableui. Our unsung heroes this week are Anthony Oots and Chris Nelson.
网上还有更糟糕的东西是没用的。只有代价需要付出。我们发布的东西有了自己的生命。它们可以像伤疤一样永久。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特、劳拉·科雷尔、托马斯·刘和帕特·沙布制作，由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。我们有拉姆廷·阿拉布伊创作的原创音乐。我们本周的无名英雄是安东尼·奥茨和克里斯·尼尔森。
We recently needed new computers for the Hidden Brain team and Anthony and Chris managed the entire process. They did the research to choose the computers that would work best for us, expedited the order, and quickly added the software we needed to work on this episode. Journalists always appreciate colleagues who get things done on a tight turnaround. Anthony and Chris came through with great collegiality and good humor. Many thanks to both. If this episode spoke to you, please share it with a friend. If you know someone who posts lots of things on social media, they might want to listen to it.
我们最近需要为“隐藏的大脑”团队购买新电脑，安东尼和克里斯负责了整个过程。他们做了研究，选择了最适合我们的电脑，加急订购，并迅速添加了我们需要制作本期节目所需的软件。记者总是很感激那些能在紧迫期限内完成工作的同事。安东尼和克里斯以极大的协作精神和幽默感完成了任务。非常感谢他们两位。如果这一集触动了你，请与朋友分享。如果你认识经常在社交媒体上发布大量内容的人，他们可能想听听这一集。
I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。